for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
University calm thank you and enjoy so
first up ionic compounds so before we
start talking about ionic compounds we
have to remember and keep in mind that
opposite charges attract while like
charges repel okay cool so ionic
compounds are composed of violence you
might be thinking well duh right well
specifically they're composed of a
cation which is positively charged and
an anion which is negatively charged now
these ions resulted because of a
transfer of electrons right so if we
think about a binary ionic compound what
that is is specifically a metal which
I'm going to abbreviate as just m and a
nonmetal which I'm going to abbreviate
as NM ok so the metal in a binary ionic
compound will what it does is it loses
electrons to the nonmetal to become the
cation okay metals lose electrons to
become cations the nonmetal will gain
nonmetal gains electrons from the metal
to become an anion ok so the metal loses
its electrons to the nonmetal ok let's
see an example of this so let's take a
look at at sodium metal which I've got
here and I've shown its electron
configuration as everything up until
neon and then 3s1 and over here we've
got chlorine right
with his electron configuration neon and
then 3s2 3p5 okay and I've drawn both
atoms here this is a sodium atom this is
a chlorine atom so you'll see here the
sodium atom has 11 protons and 11
electrons so it's neutral and the
chlorine atom has 17 protons and 17
electrons it's neutral as well now what
you should pay attention to is the idea
that sodium has one extra electron right
past its its noble gas configuration
while chlorine needs just one more
electron to reach the note the next
noble gas configuration which would be
argon so what ends up happening here is
that sodium the metal is going to lose
an electron to chlorine the nonmetal
whoa that's not right nonmetal there we
go that's right so what's going to
happen is one of these electrons right
here we'll go from these one of these
eleven is going to go over here okay
represent that by putting one electron
there ok so the sodium metal is going to
lose one electron Wow the chlorine
nonmetal gains one electron okay so what
happens to each well the sodium metal
becomes a sodium cation and the chlorine
nonmetal is going to become a chlorine
anion okay specifically the sodium went
from having 11 electrons to now have has
10 which means it has one more proton
than it does electrons so it's going to
have a positive one charge and the
chlorine went from having 17 electrons
to now a
because it gained one which is one more
electron than it has protons so it has a
negative one charge and so now what's
going on is is we've got a positive
charged particle here and a negatively
charged particle here and they're going
to be attracted okay that's what this
red dotted line between them represents
the red dotted line between them
represents the electrostatic force
between them that is there there now
attracted to each other okay
specifically this is going to be a
chemical bond even more specifically
it's going to be an ionic bond okay and
so notice here a few things is that this
sodium cation here has a noble gas
configuration and this chlorine anion
has a noble gas configuration as well
the noble gas configuration of Oregon so
they've both reached electron
configurations that are really really
stable which is why this ionic bond even
formed okay now also one thing to keep
in mind is that there's overall no net
charge because we have a sodium cation
na plus 1 and a chlorine ion also called
a chloride ion and I'll write that here
this is a chloride ion okay and it has
no net charge na plus CL minus the
overall charge is zero okay another
thing I want you to hopefully have
noticed is that the sodium decrease in
size because it lost an electron thus
increasing the effective nuclear charge
drawing the ten electrons that are left
in a little bit closer to the nucleus so
it got smaller and the chlorine gaining
an electron the effective nuclear charge
decreased so those protons are not
pulling in as as with as much force as
they were before um so this got bigger
okay um I hope you notice that okay now
you'll notice also that I have a little
asterisk
next to each of these here and the
reason why is that what we've done here
is we are both monatomic monatomic ions
and monatomic ions are just ions that
formed from a single atom sodium is a
single atom chlorine is a single atom
they both became ions okay one atom
becoming an eye on that's a monatomic
ion mono mono referring to one now there
are cases in which a small group of
atoms that are bound together will end
up having an overall charge in that
situation what you'll have is a
polyatomic ion poly meaning many okay
now that's just definition so I want to
get back to this idea of this na+ and
cl- now na+ and cl- form form this na
plus co- or nacl ionic compound and what
this actually is is an array of
alternating ions that kind of looks like
this now I've drawn it to
two-dimensional here just as flat right
where these gray positively charged
spheres are or circles that should be
spears are the sodium ions and the green
circles represent the chloride ions and
so notice that they kind of this is this
would be one sodium lie on one chlorine
ion but that's not exactly what the NICL
ionic compound is what it is is is it
it's a crystalline array of alternate
alternating ions it's a crystalline
ionic compound and this is actually
supposed to be three-dimensional and I'm
just not an artist I couldn't really
draw it perfectly but I would encourage
you to look up a 3d crystalling and
ionic compound to kind of see what it
looks like it basically looks like sort
of a cube with alternating positive and
negative charges kind of like what I've
drawn here just in 3d okay definitely
encourage you to take a look at that all
right
next up how strong are ionic bonds well
the short answer is really strong they
are incredibly strong okay so then the
question becomes how can we compare
ionic bond strength between one ionic
compound and another and what we'll do
is we'll use what's called Coulomb's law
so Coulomb's law equation is f sub e
equals K times q1 times q2 all over d
squared so what do all of these things
mean now I'm not going to get into crazy
details with this because this is not
really physics that we're studying we're
just going to use it for a chemistry so
I'm not going to go too complicated in
it but we do need to know what each of
these things represents f sub E is
whoops f sub E is the electrostatic
force ok k is Coulomb's constant which
we're actually going to ignore because
it's a constant we don't really need it
in the actual value for our purposes q1
is represents charge number one okay q2
represents charge number 2 and D
represents the distance between the
centers of charge one and charge too ok
so electrostatic force is the force
between two charges basically okay so if
we have a higher electrostatic force
what does that mean that means that
there is a stronger force between the
two charges whether it's attractive or
repulsive right if it's a higher
attractive force the molecule of the
excuse me the two charges will come
closer together it's a higher repulsive
force they'll they'll repel each other
more okay but the point is that the
strength of the force is is FB right
represented by the magnitude of Fe okay
so
earlier I mentioned that opposite
charges attract and like charges repel
so if if q1 and q2 are our source
screaming if the electrostatic force
will be an attractive force if q1 and q2
are opposite charges and the
electrostatic force will be repulsive if
q1 and q2 are like charges okay so what
we really want to pay attention to is
the cues and this devalue okay so what
we should notice is that with the
electrostatic force is proportional to Q
all right it's proportional to Q so Q is
basically the magnitude of each charge
right so if the if we have an increase
in the magnitude of charge that's going
to make this number bigger if that
number is bigger than the electrostatic
force is bigger so an increase in
magnitude of charge increases the
electrostatic force what does that mean
at least for our purposes what that
means for our purposes is that ions with
more charge will either attract or repel
each other more strongly okay so higher
magnitude of charge higher electrostatic
force the opposite would be true a lower
magnitude of charge weaker weaker
electrostatic force okay now
electrostatic force is also proportional
to 1 over d squared or 1 over the
distance between the two charges squared
okay so what does that mean well that
would mean that a decrease in the
distance between the two charges which
means a smaller D value that would mean
that we're dividing by a smaller number
which would make Fe bigger right so a
shorter distance or a decrease in the
distance between the two charges will
give us a larger electrostatic force
what does that mean that means that
smaller ions smaller ions attract or
repel each other more strongly okay so
let's use what we just learned there and
apply that to answering this question
here in which case with the ionic bond
be stronger na bound to CL or k bound to
see oh well I'd have in both of them a
CL so that's common to both that can't
be with a difference lies the difference
lies between na and k well if I have n a
bounded CL that means i have an na plus
ion and a CL minus ion and in k bound to
CEO that's k plus and Cl minus like I
said the CL minuses are common to both
so we're going to kind of ignore that so
we're comparing really na + + k + well I
notice that both of them have a charge
magnitude of +1 so they're their
differences in their cues is not going
to be much different okay however their
their their atomic size or their ionic
size is different okay what I notice is
that if I look on the periodic table
that I've drawn here including only
these elements that I'm talking about I
noticed that na is right here and K is
right here k is right below it and if
you recall from the periodic trends
atomic size and ionic size increase down
and to the left so between na + + k +
which is bigger k+ and na+ is smaller
right so since na plus is smaller and k
plus is bigger what would that mean well
if I imagine CL to be this size and in
both cases is about the same size right
na would be smaller let's just
exaggerate the point say na possibly
like this and let's just say that k plus
is bigger let's exaggerate the point
like this by making this a lot bigger if
I think about the distance between the
two centers of the charges
all right what what is what's a bigger
distance will this value here right and
this one here is smaller so where would
the force be stronger wherever the
distance between the two is smaller so I
would expect the ionic bond to be
stronger between na and cl then it would
be between K and Cl because the distance
would be smaller what about with
magnesium balance of fluorine versus
sodium out of flooring well I'd have mg
2 + + F minus here and then na + + F
minus here again we've got the anion
common to both so that's not going to be
where the difference lies right so we're
thinking about mg 2 plus and na+ okay
well mg 2 plus that means the magnitude
of its charge is higher right it's got a
magnitude it's got a Q value of 2
whereas this one has a Q value of one if
we think about it just on relative
magnitude of charge right so in that
case I would expect the electrostatic
force to be larger between mg 2 + + F
minus then I would between na + + f
minus right so the electrostatic force
would be stronger between these guys so
the ionic bond would be stronger between
mg and F then I would expect it to be
between na + F some of you are thinking
well aren't they different in size too
yeah they are slightly but na + + mg 2
plus are really really close in terms of
size so that's not where the key
difference lies even though I would
imagine mg 2 plus to be slightly smaller
again because of periodic trends but
here the difference is really the charge
the charge my attitude okay
now the question is how do we determine
chemical formulas for ionic compounds
well we must know the ion or ions that
the metal and nonmetal readily form okay
now when it comes to the the
representative elements the 1a through
8a elements we could kind of just
memorize this okay now the group 1a
elements will readily form a charge of
+1 to a plus to 3a + 38 a is the noble
gases they will not form charges okay 7a
they'll gain one so that will be
negative 16 a will be negative 25 a will
be negative 34 a it's kind of unique it
could either gain for or lose for but
for all intents and purposes we're going
to take the group for a elements to not
form ions okay so you could probably
make sense of this by looking at your
periodic table and thinking okay if I
have this atom what would it do as far
as gaining or losing electrons to form a
noble gas configuration and that should
allow this to make sense okay so how do
we determine the chemical formulas for
the ionic compounds well if you know the
eye on that those things readily form
it's fairly simple from there so if I
have em G and F magnesium and fluorine
what would the chemical formula between
them be well I'd have I have mg
magnesium in group 2a so it would be mg
2 plus and I'd have F is a halogen group
7a so it would be F minus so I have to
keep in mind also that ionic compounds
are always going to have no net charge
well I have one eye on here with the
magnesium with a plus two charge and I
have one fluorine ion with a minus one
charge and I notice here that if I want
them what if I want these guys to
combine to give an overall zero char
charge what I would need is I would need
two fluorines two of these negative 1
charges to get an overall of 2 negative
1 so that would be a negative 2 overall
charge and this and this plus two charge
and that would give me one mg and 2 f's
to give this formula okay so I'd have
the charges balancing out I have plus 2
here and then I have minus 1 but twice
right two of those minus 1 charges to
balance out with that plus two charge
now you can think about it that way and
you should understand it that way but
the shortcut way is to just do this if
you have mg 2 + + F minus 1 what you
could do is the crisscross method and
just say that this number will be the
subscript 4 for this for this element
here and this number will be the
subscript for the element here so what
you would get is mg 1 f 2 but ones do
not need to be explicitly written so
that would really just be mg f2 okay so
if we did that that quicker method for
these others here we'd have calcium
calcium is group 2a so that would be c
a2 plus and then n nitrogen that would
be group 5a so that would be n 3 minus
so the the crisscross method to that
would be the subscript here for this
other element and three and I would be
the subscript here so what that would
give us is see a three and two okay and
we can also think about this as three
calcium plus two ions and two nitrogen
minus three ions if we think about it
here i have three plus two charges so
that would be plus six charge coming
from from here and then I'd have to
negative three charges that would be a
negative six charge coming from here and
the overall charge there of course would
be zero
right now just the last one here
crisscross method mg group 2a mg 2 plus
and then I'd have 0 is a 6a element so
it'd be 0 to minus so crisscross method
and i would get mg 202 but what I would
do here is I how I'd have to reduce this
to the lowest whole number ratio ok so
this instead of being mg 202 I would
divide both of those numbers by 2
because they have that number as a
common factor and i would get mg 0 which
is is a is a chemical formula that gives
me the lowest whole number ratio of
cations to anions in what would be that
crystalline ionic compound this value or
this formula specifically is called a
formula unit because it tells me like i
said the lowest whole number ratio of
cations anions instead of saying i have
two magnesium ions for every two oxygen
ions i can just say i have one magnesium
ion for every one oxygen ion in the
ionic compound that has that is made up
of mg 2 + + 0 to negative anyway i hope
that video was helpful thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying